since 1990 the number of gun deaths
worldwide has reached six point five
million three quarters of gun deaths
occur in just 15 countries Latin America
is home to some of the world's most
violent countries by murder rate El
Salvador Venezuela and Guatemala are the
top three countries for deaths caused by
guns per population these Latin American
countries are marred by corruption
organized crime and a dysfunctional
criminal justice system that further
fuels the problem the availability of
guns in the United States is another
concern for these countries an estimated
200,000 guns a year that were first sold
in the United States are smuggled over
the southern border and used in violent
crimes in Latin America and the
Caribbean in the United States the
constitutional right to bear arms has
led to looser regulations and easier
access to firearms this contributes to
the 30,000 men women and children who
were killed with guns each year mass
shootings attract their headlines but in
fact these make up only 0.2% of gun
deaths 60% of gun related deaths are in
fact suicide
America's suicide rate increased by 25
percent between 1999 and 2015 of nearly
45,000 taking their own lives in 2015
alone half of these suicides were
carried out with guns though guns aren't
the most common method of suicide they
are the most lethal other wealthy
countries have far lower rates of gun
violence in Japan if you want to own a
gun you must pass a written exam and a
shooting range test alongside a series
of mental health drug in criminal record
tests
it has virtually eradicated gun crime
after a mass shooting in 1996 Australia
introduced an effective buyback scheme
of firearms in the 20 years following
the bag there was an accelerated decline
in total gun deaths but in America the
House of Representatives has not voted
on a single measure to prevent gun
violence and in some states such as
Texas where students at public colleges
can now carry concealed handguns the law
has actually loosened easy access to
firearms will continue to be the main
driver of America's gun debt